[Music]  side note no bread makers were injured  in the making of this video  as you can probably gather this is not  your average bread maker nor is this  your average bread oven nor is it your  average bread  this is shotis puri and in georgia and  that translates to well  bread  story  [Music]  needs  a toner oven is essential to the making  of shotis puri after the oven is built  and the heat is turned up to the highest  level for six to seven hours the walls  of the oven are covered in a salt-based  liquid and diving in to get the bread as  close to the fire is just a part of the  job  uh  foreign  as if diving into a clay pot isn't  intense enough this thing hits  temperatures of 750 to 900 degrees  fahrenheit the end result is a special  bread with a salty twist  that's eaten on special occasions like  birthdays weddings christmas and new  years it's hotshot  watch  [Music]  you